bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin alors est ce qu'on
peut déjà mesurer le risque qu'on
représente justement les contrefaçons
en ce qui concerne le risque c'est tout
sauf une surprise
partout et toujours les malfaiteurs sont
des prédateurs opportuniste c'est à dire
que contrairement à vous et à moi qui
avons un métier le monde criminel n'a
pas de métier des termites et ce sont
des gens qui observent la situation qui
dans la société ont des palpeurs ondes
et des gens qui leur a fourni ces
informations étaient qu'ils voient une
opportunité pour par le vol à main armée
par la contrefaçon par la contrebande ou
autres saisir une opportunité un peu
comme un fauve qui tourne autour du
troupeau de zébus et qui saute sur un
élément faible et qui après celle des
vaures nous les bandits sont qu'en marge
de la société ce sont des parasites de
la société
que ce soit dans le monde numérique où
que ce soit dans le monde physique donc
depuis toujours quand il ya eu le sida
les mêmes ou leurs ancêtres vendait des
préservatifs de mauvaise qualité ou
quand il y a eu les premiers médicaments
servant à augmenter les performances
sexuelles qui sont précipité dessus pour
vendre du foie gras et bien cette fois
ci ils vendront de faux vaccins mais
c'est toujours la même pratique ce sont
des prédateurs opportuniste alors
justement quelles sont les cibles de ces
prédateurs opportunistes comme vous les
qualifier ce que ce sont finalement les
populations les plus fragiles on les
imagine non ce sont pas forcément les
plus fragiles ce sont les plus naïfs
ce sont ceux qui se font avoir par
défaut investissements en bourse sont
ceux qui se font avoir par les
possibilités d'investir de l'argent avec
des taux profit l'immense de 20 30 et 40
%
j'avais dans la population il ya des
gens qui sont un peu méfiant et d'autres
qui comme absolument tout ce qu'on leur
présente et bien c'est assez naïf la
queue
cela se les propositions seront faites
dans le temps vous savez il ya ce qui
s'appelle et les escroqueries nigériane
sur internet c'est à dire vous recevez
un mail d'une dame qui dit je vais
mourir d'un cancer vous met sympathique
voulez vous gagner 100 millions de
dollars et il suffit de m'envoyer 1000
pour que je fasse mon virements et pour
se rendre est en échange il ya toujours
comme ça la naïveté humaine étant hélas
pas forcément chez les gens
matériellement fragile mais c'est les
gens psychologiquement un peu naïfs ont
un peu niais vous avez un public pour ça
songez que même dans les élites de la
ville de new york
il ya un centre financier immense le
financier riboud madoff a réussi à
escroquer des gens qui de même été
immensément fortunés qui aurait dû quand
même réfléchir un peu avant d'investir
leur argent dans ce qui n'était qu'une
comme on dit une pyramide de ponzi
donc ce ne sont pas forcément les gens
les plus modestes
d'abord ceux qui seront ça ne peut se
faire que par voie d'internet comprenez
donc ceux qui sont en dehors de
l'internet c'est-à-dire par exemple dans
les zones à peu isolés de la couverture
numérique comme en afrique et en asie
une court aucun risque
vous n'avez pas à voir des individus qui
vont sonner à votre porte avec des faux
vaccins mais en revanche pour la
population a ayant accès aux réseaux
numériques et paix susceptible de céder
un petit peu comment dire aux
entreprises d'escroquerie aux honneurs
filous qui sont capables de vous
proposer des choses pareilles oui ça
cette population est à risque alors
justement depuis le début de la pandémie
cauvier 19 à ce qu'on a déjà constaté la
vente de contrefaçon
je mesure bien entendu la
caractéristique de ces groupes c'est
l'extrême rapidité avec laquelle qu'ils
agissent quand par exemple madame
clinton a été battu dans sa tentative de
prendre le pouvoir et finalement obama
le président obama
une investiture d
crac le lendemain le jour même si ça se
trouve vous aviez des mails qui arrivait
chez les gens en disant bonjour j'étais
dans la campagne de hillary clinton il
me reste un million de dollars voulez
vous qu'on partage etc
leur réactivité est extrême car
naturellement tout comme les vaccins et
tout comme les médicaments d'ailleurs
les escroqueries dont une date de
péremption il ya une date d'utilisation
limite très vite au bout de quelques
semaines
les plus naïfs ou les plus simples
mentalement ont compris que c'était une
arnaque et donc refusent d'y marcher
il faut donc aller très vite donc au
début c'est sans doute la raison pour
laquelle interpol a averti maintenant
c'est que cet encours d'ores et déjà
c'est ça n'est pas une menace dans
l'avenir alors au moment où nous nous
parlons il y à des sites sur lesquels on
vous dit vous voulez vous être les
premiers à thaksin et voulait me voir le
meilleur vaccin
levac ce que je dis n'importe quoi elle
vaccin sud coréen est meilleur que le
vaccin chinois et donc il faut
l'utiliser
voilà le genre de choses qui les a
présentés à l'heure alors on imagine que
la balle est aussi dans qu'en maintenant
des autorités des pouvoirs publics
est-ce qu'il ya déjà par exemple si on
prend le cas de la france où tu as
européens ce qui a déjà des plans pour
dire de prévention contre ce type de
contrefaçon
bien sûr il y a dans la police nationale
il y attend de renseignement intérieur
il y attend la gendarmerie des services
maintenant qui s'occupe des infractions
commises dans le monde numérique
vous avez dans la rue des gendarmes qui
s'occupe de la sécurité du monde
physique assez ceux qui mettent des
contraventions aux gens qui vont trop
vite tout y ont volé des poules dans les
villages mais vous avez aussi maintenant
une gendarmerie une police et un
enseignement du monde numérique
justement pour ça pour éviter que ça se
propage mais naturellement de telles
opérations d' arnaque à l'échelle
internationale aujourd'hui sur le virus
contre la copie de 19 et demain sur
autre chose
ces opérations internationales sont très
lourdes et longues à monter il y à un
danger très grave celui des faux
médicaments
les faux médicaments vous mettez de la
poudre de perlimpinpin dans une boîte
vendée comme étant un médicament
anti-cancéreux naturellement pour des
gens qui sont pas avertis et sur
certains continents 30 à 40 % des
médicaments sont faux contre eux fait
sous dosés naturellement c'est dangereux
par exemple contre la malle arrière vous
pensez vaccinés contre la malaria et à
la fin vous en mourrez tout en pensant
que vous aviez fait le nécessaire
donc toutes ces escroqueries là elle
repose toujours sur le même principe il
ya une occasion à saisir il ya une
affaire à faire et la police
naturellement est là pour punir et pour
saisir ces arnaques mais c'est très
lourd songez que pour monter une
opération contre les faux médicaments
soient europol c'est à dire la
coordination des polices à l'échelle de
l'union européenne soit interpol même
plus d'un an à monter une opération
comme ça hors la durée de vie d'une
telle opération son efficacité
là où les bandits vont pouvoir récolter
de l'argent et puis après ça disparaître
en envoyant des flacons rempli d'eau ou
n'importe quoi elle est lors de quelques
semaines donc il y a toujours la société
des gens honnêtes a toujours un temps de
retard du fait de du fait que la justice
ne peut pas non plus aller trop vite
nous sommes des états de droit si la
justice de la chromie d'aller commettre
des erreurs
merci beaucoup à vous à xavier reforme
assez d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes criminologue